I don't consider myself a marathon
runner I'm not like the elite guys from
Kenya and all those country that's
that's basically all they do I'm a
working man I get up and go to work
every day I serve people and that's the
most rewarding thing about my job it's
when I get out there and I'll see all
these wonderful people man and I can
give them their packages and that's what
I do is they're paying me to be a
servant for the people out in LA I work
for the post office that's specially how
I get my training in is from my job
in 1986 I ran my first marathon
[Music]
there was one of the craziest thing that
I've ever done in my life and the
coolest thing about my first marathon
was I ran it backwards I was out there
so long it was no one at the finish line
as a matter of fact I finished in last
place
cool it that they gave me my first
certificate with completion of the LA
Marathon and they had backwards on it
which was cool after the race that I'll
say oh I might want to do this again so
the following year I ran it back once
again I run the best shoes in the world
man
I went payless shoes in the early days
of the marathon everyone about people
they have only $150 pair of shoes
they're sitting on the curb nursing
their blisters and I run back and say
look pay less but I just keep going and
laugh at them I've been running in
tennis shoes every year why pay more we
do pay less
well found three when it came along I
wanted to be creative again so I picked
up a basketball and I drove her to
basketball for 26.2 miles that's what
the marathon was about when we first was
introduced to it get out there and do
something crazy it really took your mind
off a lot of pain it just let me realize
that regardless of what this marathon is
all about hey I don't mean to something
crazier than that so I know I got this I
[Music]
was 11 B 1011 B 10 is every treatment
you know you're just a grunt everybody
that went in during the Johnson
administration you was going in there to
go in the jungle all the rice paddies I
can remember the first day in Vietnam a
dude who was I guess he was disgruntled
he shot us four off you hear me man
he shot his foot off so he can go home I
saw that and from then on it was just
crazy stuff happening something was
changing I was adapting to the
environment when you're afraid you know
all your senses scare up man you want to
survive now I was in survival mode when
I got here doctor here to be a car way
out there like a smelly so that's when I
knew I will turn into her a stone-cold
animal man
it fit the environment that's the rest
we weren't weeble animals out there
killing up each other and stuff man
they knew something was wrong with me I
overheard my mother say they don't
messed up myself a lot of times I will
wake up the room would be all messed up
because I'm fighting I'm fighting in my
sleep and not even knowing it
[Music]
the negative images are always there and
you just embrace it and just keep Ronan
is part of what I'm going to deal with
for the rest of my life
the morale thought was is something that
that helped you know just have to grow
because you put yourself through
something and you don't been through
something that was money tougher than
its brother and I hate dancing like a
piece of cake
and as cheers progressively started
coming up over and over I'll say order
says this is good therapy this is real
good thing I'm gonna try this again next
year
sometimes things trigger memories like I
could wake up in the morning soon when
the Sun is about to rise and look at the
skies around the sort of like a Viet Nam
morning
the cool thing about it it's all right
you know I'm alright with that now it's
just something that I have to excel and
just keep going on with my life my life
is getting better and better
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm involved in a group I've never been
involved in something that's been around
for 30 years I mean I work for most of
it but never party but that's livelihood
this legacy thing and we are part of
Pelle
now a tradition here we are this is
brown town 30 I don't know where it's
going in the next five years but I just
want to be a part of it because I've
been here since day one I am a legacy
runner we're all in our 60s and 70s now
man you know we're not three chickens
anymore it's not about how long you out
there it's about completing the race so
this put a different spin on me when it
still taking me like I was some time to
complete sometimes six hours but my
whole thing was to complete it so I
could stay in the game oh man I feel
like right now but going for number 30
it's what it was really all about so I
had to dig deep inside my soul and make
sure that I do what I had to do to get
this number 30 man you know it was
brutal it was hot and I don't feel good
[Applause]
yeah
we don't need to do this are you okay
didn't need to get a medic over here
okay hey kiddos get a medic yeah you
okay
Johnny look stay with me buddy
I'm gonna call nine-one-one
hi I'm and we have a marathon runner who
is collapsed
[Music]
when you get to that nineteen mile mark
and you know you got seven miles and you
think about that minutes go haunt you
let's go tell you now but you got to put
that aside and just go you gotta grind
it out cuz life ain't nothing but a
grind man
[Music]
if you pray that get up and go do it
just go do it keep going you'll get to
the finish line I know I feel pain
sometimes my ladies and a king and stuff
but hey that's a sign of being alive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
says you
[Music]
you
[Music]